hey guys what's up i'm alana and today
i'm playing more of alien isolation and
we're back where we left off mmm still
trying to get to comms i believe oh yes
okay both and then yes okay i'm doing
the thing i'm doing the thing what do
you want from me why is the thing note
whatever you okay thank you what's new
y'all
yes I do a chargeback her and anything
else in you
flare yeah I'll leave the radio always
make uh-huh that sounds interesting
it's really just a very large series of
hallways which I guess is like what
ninety percent of this game is really
okay where am I going back the way I
came
ooh one of them what is this
what you gonna do oh well thank you Oh
everyone hey friend give me the thing
okay thank you it's so nice sure have a
lot of stuff hey buddy yes new let me
get me to contact my ship your jug thank
you there's gotta be another way inside
okay well no oh can i hack this well I
feel like hacking that in front of him
isn't a good idea so let's oh god just
you perpetually stare at me he does he
does I don't like it uh-oh not good not
good
this looks hackable okay let's do the
thing oh this is near okay huh oh [ __ ]
no no no I'm really bad at this poof huh
you're like an alarm probably get going
off of how to [ __ ] that up okay he's
good it's all good flashlight batteries
huh that's so much stuff maxed oh that's
not the right button how do I don't know
how to that one not that one that one
that one yes there we go I'd forgotten
how to do this so we press lb to build
and then you go yes yes do the thing ok
I didn't do it right south beach but
damn it that that one no yes bat lb and
then you go ok thank you it's a weirdly
complicated crafting system LBI missing
that thing of course that thing maybe I
should build a noisemaker that seems
like I had anything to build do that
that that yes thank you
don't know what it does but I have one
nail so that's good
alright know where I am today let me
know oh it's me okay okay don't you
recognize me listen to me we've got to
reestablish long-range dedications upon
your becoming get back I'm warning you
look doc oh jesus oh God whoa
oh man dang holy crap please don't
notice me like we said good day there
what is sassy sassy little thing like
good day girl yeah how you like that or
something yeah just wander around events
feel it seems like a little what you
doing this game actually I really know
if we want to leave now what he sees me
oh oh that looks like a camera oh is it
your camera
appears to be a security camera if I
can't do anything about it nope
how I hmm let me go do this wait till it
gets to that point and then Jimmy ever
that shouldn't be too hard right I just
have to be really slow it was the
problem hope the only a dozen walk out
door hey ah looks like you can see there
oh no no no there's no disturbance no
disturbance I promise friend oh lordy no
no no disturbance I promise
not right here ya know oh oh oh god no
oh god oh oh oh no if I walk okay okay
go go go go go go go shut the thing shut
it shut it shut shut the thing oh oh I
didn't know it like that you're closing
on his face I need to contacted people
now this is gonna be good I know I was
worried about alien now have those
things to worry about his will good hey
Lina worry about not good no aliens east
oh no oh no he's coming so I owner oh no
he's not okay yes hello torrents I would
love to talk to you desperate to talk to
you even friend
the wrong way I'm facing that way and
I'm supposed to go so well it should be
Sadie thing here some somewhere savvy
thingy my bad
yet
am I just reading the map but totally
wrong might be okay well probably gonna
have to go back up here anyway let's
just get back to you and I just assumed
that we cannot take them out so maybe
I'll avoid the synthetics at all costs
but I don't think I'm gonna be very good
at that I saw one man what did it go
when in doubt jump in a bat talaash mant
it's not a bad oh well it just goes back
this way though oh it goes up yay I
think this looks good looks
communications e yes hey friends I know
that's just great I should see that
coming really some station I can contact
well you'd think but you know stuffs not
really going your way right now oh that
one and then that one and then that one
okay yeah thank you
hello scrap okay what's up why was this
one locked off when I was usually out
well I did do that okay
already hood that just don't see
anything else in here well that was not
productive for it iris West agree now
although I over here
a long way away
gifs go dang it won't pasta I don't want
to do this I don't know
hold the motion travel right now should
I be
no way maybe this thought this is just
for sure my ailing was it was tell me
all the things are as well and I think
so oh no oh no no no oh no oh no please
something has only one yet I thought he
comes up on the truck oh oh he does oh
no he does oh god he's right there [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no no nothing nothing
don't yes thank you there are indeed
more pressing medals oh my god I was so
nervous just then oh holy crap
oh ok and so we won this my cell I don't
know what a safe way they're supposed to
be what right there I could have I'd it
ok see we go through y'all it's just one
behind me maybe ok she always gonna be
someone in you know
yes hello friend I'm trying trying to
respond it's like all I'm doing right
now oh no not again
yes I would love to help you
was he why is he going to not come back
why has he done that you're not gonna
come back this way because that seems
like a thing that you should do I'm
trying so hard to respond to your I
never you don't even know I'm risking my
life for you there's a dude who just
walked through here and if he finds me
I'm gonna die does he just like
disappeared in here he's not showing up
anymore that's not comforting at all how
did he go where'd he go there you go I
have no idea yes yes good thing I am
seeks in huh
okay save your thingy oh no oh my god oh
god okay no we're fine I just wanted to
say I just wanted to save that's all I
wanted to do oh this is a safety it was
real I think they just wanted say Oh God
well at least someone seems to have
killed that guy where I was thinking
they were impossible to kill oh man just
safe thingy come on come on why am i
okay so sorry I'm right now okay oh no
oh no oh I'm gonna die I'm gonna die nor
hey friend and I'm being nice I'm not
doing anything [ __ ]
no why oh [ __ ]